federal lawmakers are demanding answers
from the FAA this morning after a 60
minutes report revealed allegiance airs
alarming safety record in a letter to
the Department of Transportation Florida
Senator Bill Nelson called for an
investigation into the FAA s enforcement
actions Chris Van Cleef is at Dulles
International Airport outside of
Washington Chris good morning good
morning 60 minutes found more than a
hundred incidents involving Allegiant
airlines and mechanical issues that
includes midair engine failures and
malfunctions or problems with flight
control systems now Senator Bill Nelson
of Florida the ranking Democrat on the
Commerce Committee is citing that report
in his call for an investigation into
how the FAA is regulating the industry
and Allegiant in particular writing the
traveling public deserves to know
whether the FAA is conducting thorough
safety oversight of Allegiant the FAA
tells CBS News we welcome any outside
review of our safety oversight system
Allegiant maintains the 60 minutes
report is a quote misleading narrative
while welcoming an analysis of its
safety culture late yesterday
representative Steve Cohen of Tennessee
also sent a letter this time to
Transportation Secretary Elaine Chao
expressed expressing concern over what
was in that 60 minutes report John Chris
thanks